foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear now as should be apparent uh from
some of my other videos other movies
that I've covered on this series I'm a
pretty big fan of kind of slow burn
psychological horror
so when I started hearing that this
particular movie which actually ended up
uh I think it premiered at Sundance like
last January of 2022 and kind of had a
little bit of Buzz surrounding it when I
found out that it actually just dropped
on shutter a little while back I you
know kind of brewed myself a cup of
peppermint tea and I said I'm gonna sit
down and watch watch her
sorry about that I just kind of feel
like everybody like you almost have to
do it you almost have to it's the law
you have to make that joke okay so
Watcher is the feature length debut film
of uh writer director Chloe okudo now
she's probably best known uh you know
her previous credit that is best known
was probably directing the storm drain
segment from VHS 94 like the um
Anthology film from 2021
so on this one though she's working from
a screenplay by Zach Ford who also
produced it it seems like he wrote the
original script and then she kind of
like you know rewrote it to suit her own
tastes I guess or her own Vision
um and the vision that she seems to be
wanting to get across is very steeped in
um yeah it's it I mean the whole thing
is just like very foreboding and I think
like the whole thing too is
homaging uh particularly Alfred
Hitchcock uh you know and very
particularly rare window but I also got
a real Roman Polanski Vibe um
particularly the tenant but there are
some kind of like there's some stuff
like repulsion and there's kind of like
slightly Rosemary's Baby in here and I'm
not saying that it's like a rip-off
necessarily but the um the influences
are like pretty readily apparent and not
there's anything wrong with that holy
crap I mean if you're going to be
influenced by something those are some
really good movies to be influenced by
and that's all I'm saying
so watch her it doesn't do anything
particularly new plot wise um it's
pretty much just a very simple stalker
Thriller type of movie but the execution
of it I think really elevates it I mean
it's just a very elegant it's a very
classic type of movie like I don't
necessarily want to say throwback but it
is just like a very classic Thriller
type movie like I said very much in the
vein of Hitchcock
um and honestly I thought it was pretty
damn great I got really into it
um I think the acting performances in
this are really good and again
um another thing that elevates it I
think they're very subtle and I think
that really helps with the narrative a
lot uh the cinematography I can't
remember the cinematographer's name I
apologize for that but I think he's
Dutch and um he just the way he shoots
everything it's just like he gives
everything this real unsettling Vibe but
he's not real like overt or showy about
it and I think it worked really well
also I have to say too I really like the
score for this they used a lot of um
Johann Sebastian particularly like the
well-tempered clavier or whatever and
that was in there a lot and I thought I
thought that was really cool I thought
that like fitted in a lot with uh with
kind of the whole vibe of the movie
now one caveat though when I say this
movie is a slow burn I mean it it's
pretty slow paced
um I didn't mind and actually it didn't
seem slow to me at all like I was just
riveted the whole time
um because really I mean from my
perspective at least every interaction
in this every event every conversation
no matter how innocuous it seemed on the
surface was just kind of Laden with real
ominous overtones but one criticism that
I saw like most people seem to really
like this movie it has like 88 like
positive or something like that but from
some of the people that commented on
shutter and commented elsewhere the main
criticism I saw mostly other than oh
we've seen it's just like a thriller
like the other ones but mostly people
were like oh it's like too slow it's too
boring and they couldn't sit through it
now I really don't agree I did not find
it boring in the slightest but I'm just
giving you a heads up right here if
you're not real into kind of like Slow
Burn and more like psychological horror
because things happen but there's not
like any really big like uh kind of Gore
violence or anything like that until the
end like you know what I mean so if
that's gonna bother you then maybe give
it a pass but I really really liked it a
lot so in the lead we have horror
darling Micah Monroe uh obviously best
known for it follows uh that was kind of
her breakout role from 2014. she's been
in a couple things since then but I
think that's probably what most horror
fans know her from and I think that like
um it seems the horror Community we're
very excited about this movie
particularly because she was going to be
in it because I think this is the first
horror movies that she's done since then
uh so she's in this she plays a
character named Julia and she's a young
former actress who is married to this
kind of Big Shot marketing executive
named Francis now this guy is played by
Carl glossman and I was like holy crap
that Glassman and gluceman I'm not
really sure how to pronounce his last
name I apologize again because I hate
getting people's name wrong but you know
what I mean
um and I was like man I've seen that
dude before he's been a lot of stuff I
think he was in some Gaspar Noe movies
um but I think I recognize him from the
neon demon because I saw that not too
long ago
so Francis the husband uh he's recently
received a promotion and he and Julia
end up moving to Bucharest Romania from
New York city so francis's Mom was
Romanian
and he's fluent in the language uh but
Julia doesn't speak a word of it it's
kind of implied they don't go a lot into
Julia's past or her history like a lot
of it's just very like I said very
subdued very subtle like a lot of it is
kind of implication or you're kind of
left to fill in your own blanks
um I kind of got the impression that
Julia was kind of like at a point where
she was very adrift in her life
like she says at one point that she's
like they're like oh he used to be an
actor and she was like yeah I just I
realized it wasn't for me
um but she really kind of seems unsure
of what exactly she's going to do now
um you know and like moving to Bucharest
to support her husband like his big job
and everything like that it sort of
seemed like well that's the thing to do
because I don't really have anything
else in particular going on and I can't
really you know it's not really what I
wanted but you know this might as well
do this is do anything else that's kind
of like maybe I'm reading too much into
it but that's kind of like the
impression of her character that I got
so the couple runs this really nice
apartment and Francis proceeds to you
know work very long hours because like I
said they gave him this big promotion
and he's I guess like trying to justify
the company's faith in him and so to
that end too not only does he work long
hours during the day but like at night
he's always kind of schmoozing with
clients like trying to get new so you
know like taking him to cocktail parties
and dinner and blah blah blah you know
how that kind of thing goes so he
basically is leaving Julia alone much of
the time now she is trying to learn
Romanian she's got like the language app
on her phone and we see her like trying
to learn it
um but there's still like a really huge
like language barrier now when Francis
is around he can translate for her but
when he's not around she struggles with
like really really simple tasks you know
what I mean it's like even just going
out for coffee or going to a museum or
something like that just becomes fraught
with difficulties because you know it's
just there's so much potential for
misunderstanding and it's just she's
really having a hard time
so not surprisingly Julia begins to feel
very isolated and I think right here
this was a good decision Chloe acuno the
director she decided not to translate or
closed caption any of the Romanian
conversations of which there are many
um and that puts us unless obviously
unless we speak Romanian which I do not
um but it puts us in the same boat as
Julia
um kind of feeling detached and excluded
and sort of like hovering around the
fringes of other people's lives and
never being able to be fully involved
because everybody's having all of these
conversations and stuff and you have no
idea what they're saying now not long
into their stay in Bucharest Julia
notices the silhouette of a dude at the
window of an apartment like across the
way like across the street
now he seems to be sitting there every
night staring into her window though she
can't really tell exactly what he's
looking at because he's always in Shadow
so it's like is he look in the window or
is he just kind of sitting there like
you couldn't you can't really tell it's
very very creepy but his sort of
pervasive presence it seems like every
evening like she kind of opens the
curtains and there he is he's just kind
of sitting there like the Shadow and
she's like what the [ __ ]
um it just kind of like puts her on edge
as it would you know what I mean and
these emotions that she feels about that
get exacerbated when a woman in the
nearby apartment building like I don't
think it's the same one that's across
the street but it's one like a little
bit down the street she gets beheaded
like pretty much almost beheaded she's
murdered now through a conversation with
francis's workmates who come over for
dinner one evening it's revealed that
there's actually like a serial killer
known as the spider who has been on the
loose for quite a while and has already
killed several other women there's also
a little bit of a hint that but maybe
Francis the husband like knew about this
kind of stuff like knew it was going on
but didn't tell her and she didn't know
because she didn't speak Romanian so
she's like watching the news and being
like well what are they saying and he
seems like reluctant to tell her so he's
almost kind of like
um infantilizing her a little bit I want
to say there is kind of like and I think
she actually accuses him of that very
thing like at some point in the movie so
she he's like trying to keep her maybe
kind of trying to protect her a little
bit but it's a little bit like
paternalistic you know what I mean it's
a little bit like condescending
so yeah so there's a serial killer
running around and he didn't want her to
know and like uh it's he's apparently
like getting closer because it just
happened like a few buildings away and
they actually see they don't see the
body or anything like that but they see
when they're out walking one night they
see like the ambulance and then like
they see the guy in there that found the
body and like there's all this stuff and
you know so then they find out later
like what happened so as I said you know
her husband's working all the time she
doesn't really she's kind of like at
Loose Ends she doesn't really know what
to do she doesn't know anybody so she
kind of just starts wandering a little
bit aimlessly like around the city she's
trying to kind of familiarize herself
with the with the place and like trying
to practice her Romanian a little bit
like I said going to coffee shops and
stuff but while she's doing that she
starts getting the very distinct feeling
that she's being followed
now at first she isn't sure if maybe
she's just imagining it I mean she's
been under a lot of stress she just
moved to another country and you know
there's culture shock she doesn't speak
the language she's feeling very lonely
um and you know the whole thing about
the serial killer I mean yeah that's a
concern too so she's kind of like well
maybe I'm just being paranoid
um so this one particular day she's kind
of like feeling like there's somebody
kind of behind her but so she Ducks into
like a movie theater and she's gonna
like hang out in there for a little
while and then she starts kind of
turning like surreptitiously like
checking out the other patrons or
whatever uh but then this dude comes and
like sits like directly behind her
um which [ __ ] God damn it I [ __ ]
hate that like even though like the
theater is almost empty there's only
maybe like four or five other people in
there I don't you [ __ ] hate that like
when you're at the movies and it's like
the whole theater is empty and then some
[ __ ] just like has to sit in the
same row as you or like just in front of
you or right behind just like [ __ ] off
like you feel like whole theater just
get the [ __ ] away from me I got I hate
when people do that so I really kind of
like felt it when you know this creepy
dude like sits and you can't really see
it see him because it's kind of like
he's kind of blurry and then he kind of
like goes behind her and she's just like
oh [ __ ] I don't like that and I don't
blame her one bit so she actually kind
of panics and was like [ __ ] this and she
runs out
now she goes into a grocery store next
and she's pretty certain that the same
dude that was behind her she didn't
really she didn't see his face like she
just saw his shoes
um so she's pretty sure that the same
guy like followed her to the grocery
store and is kind of like peering at her
like around the aisles and stuff like
while she's trying to shop and [ __ ] so
she like flips out
um she kind of like flees through the
back of the store but she also starts to
become convinced too that not only is
this creep like obviously following her
around for some reason but she's now
pretty sure that this is the same guy
who sits in the window and watches her
from his apartment even though like I
said she can't really see that guy but
still she's like pretty certain she has
a gut feeling that it's the same dude
now her husband Francis who is almost
never at home is initially kind of
supportive or as supportive as you
probably could be in this situation he
goes with her to the grocery store and
asks if he can see this CCTV footage so
he can see what she's so upset about
like what the guy looks like like what
exactly he was doing that was so sketchy
so while they're watching it she's
trying to explain it's like look watch
what he's doing watch what he's doing
but to him it doesn't really seem like
he's doing anything overtly Sinister
even though because he wasn't there and
he didn't like see the whole like you
know context or how she felt or anything
like that so he's kind of like looking
at her and you can tell like by the look
at his face that he's really starting to
doubt her that he's kind of starting to
think hey maybe she's making something
out of nothing because she's under so
much stress now eventually she does
actually end up meeting a friend who's
this really nice girl this really nice
woman who lives next door named Irina
who is uh you know her she's her
neighbor and she lives alone she had a
boyfriend but she got rid of him and
[ __ ] like that and uh she's also like a
dancer and a club like a stripper or
whatever so she befriends her so one
evening uh she's kind of over there at
Arena's apartment they're kind of like
you know drinking some wine and having
some girl time and so she gets a little
bit tipsy and she comes home to her own
apartment and she sees the dude watching
from the window again now she's kind of
like I said a little bit inebriated and
has like a little bit of that Dutch
courage going on or whatever it is they
call it and she's also kind of been
bolstered a little bit by irina's sort
of like yeah [ __ ] him kind of attitude
like toward her ex-boyfriend in
particular
um and she's a lot more confident and a
lot more assertive and I think so uh so
Julia is just kind of like you know kind
of bolstered up by that like I said so
she decides okay I'm gonna I'm gonna see
for sure if this dude is actually like
looking at me or if he's just looking at
something else and I'm just being crazy
so he so she like raised her hand like
she's waving at him right
so then like nothing happens at first
and she's just like oh that's me I was
just being silly and paranoid and stuff
like that but then like after a little
bit the dude raises his hand like waving
back so she flips out because she knows
for sure now that this dude is just
sitting there looking at her which like
I said that's not [ __ ] illegal but it
is really really [ __ ] creepy and uh
yeah I would be wigging out as well so
she flips out and she convinces Francis
to call the police
so from that point forward it's pretty
much a classic gaslighting scenario
Julia is pretty adamant that this guy
has nefarious intentions he's like
creepy as [ __ ] but Francis and the
police and everybody else that she tells
about it other than Arena who seems to
be like more understanding obviously
because she's a stripper and she's a
woman and she's been through the same
[ __ ] too so she's just kind of like yeah
if you think something sketchy probably
something sketchy
um but Francis and the cops just think
she's blowing everything out of
proportion you know she's just being
hysterical and they you know they point
out the man hasn't actually done
anything to you
um you know it could just be that he
lives in the neighborhood and he just
happened to be in the grocery store he
just happened to be in the movie theater
you know you're just imagining that he's
like stalking you and stuff like that he
hasn't done anything like that he can be
charged for or that looks all that
suspicious to them and you know and they
point out you know Julie's been through
under a lot of stress lately like I said
she's you know so she's maybe not in the
best frame of mind also she's in a
different culture maybe she's misreading
some signals maybe she just doesn't
understand and like um you know the way
the guy is reacting maybe that's normal
in this culture and she doesn't get it
because she's American or something like
that so Julia who is very frustrated
as you would be by this kind of like by
the dudes like blowing her off she's
like well I'm gonna follow the dude
myself just to make sure she wants to
make sure that am I correct that this
dude that was following me around to the
grocery store in the movie theater is
this the same guy that sits in the
window and like watches me all the time
because she's she feels like it's the
same guy but she wants to be absolutely
sure that it is so she kind of like
starts to I don't know if I'd say she
goes under investigation but she does
kind of like casually like start to sort
of follow him around and this
unfortunately uh ends up making her look
maybe like to other people even more
delusional because it's starting to seem
like she's the one that's stalking him
and then he's just like this hapless
victim who's I'm just doing normal [ __ ]
and now this like crazy lady thinks that
I'm a stalker and like she's stalking me
now and blah blah blah so that's so
there's kind of like a little bit of a
flip going on and I don't really want to
spoil it any farther than that because I
really did like this movie and I think
it had like some really good twists and
turns
um but you know I as I said the story
isn't all that original it's just a very
classic like Thriller stalker type thing
but there's definitely something to be
said for taking
a premise like this just Back to Basics
and just making a really solid kind of
tension-filled Thriller that isn't
really ostentatious or you know anything
or showy or anything like that but is
really good at keeping you invested and
keeping you guessing where it's going
next while kind of staying really
admirably
um restrained and very grounded in
reality I mean uh the direction like
Chloe acuno's direction of this is very
assured and I like that they align your
perspective like the viewer's
perspective with Julia is like right
away so all the way through you're
really sympathizing with her you're
feeling her anguish her self-doubt
um and also kind of her building
resentment at not being believed or not
having her concerns taken seriously you
know it's just kind of like I mean like
most women uh you know like 99 of women
I feel like um I've been in the same
position as Julia many times you're
pretty sure like a strange dude is up to
something sketchy and possibly
potentially dangerous but then like when
you try to tell someone else about it it
sounds kind of lame and it's like you
know oh maybe it was nothing to worry
about maybe I'm just overreacting I'm
overthinking things blah blah you just
don't trust your instincts and that's
something that a lot of women deal with
it's really really not a good feeling
and this movie really nailed what that's
like and it also has like the added
alienation factor of also being in an
unfamiliar country where you don't know
anyone and you don't speak the language
so it's hard to get help and people are
having conversations about you maybe and
you don't really like know what they're
talking about I mean maybe so the thing
about it maybe
because I was reading one review that
said maybe this movie uh hits different
like if you're a woman and probably it
does I'm not saying that a man can't
enjoy it obviously because I just think
it's a good movie across the board but I
think maybe maybe if you're a woman you
would get more out of it I don't know
maybe I'm just like talking out my ass
I'm not entirely sure but a lot of what
she went through like the you know the
struggles that she had like to get
believed and all that kind of stuff like
really resonated with me and actually
one thing one and this is kind of like a
smaller thing but it's sort of like a
microcosm of like the bigger thing it
happens in the movie A couple of times
and it almost made me feel like crying
because it was just kind of like it was
just I could feel the frustration and
I've been in like similar situations
myself there was a there was a couple
scenes where Francis and his colleagues
like they're at work functions or like
you know the some of his colleagues like
come over for dinner or whatever and
they sort of like insist on speaking
Romanian in front of her most of the
time even though they can all speak
English and it almost seems as though
they're deliberately trying to isolate
her further and maybe they're not doing
it like to be mean but the fact that
they're so thoughtless about it and it's
like you know that she's just sitting
there excluded looking at him going gee
sure do wish that I knew what you
[ __ ] were saying you know what
I mean um it just seemed really rude and
uh you know because I hate that I hate
when like people who spit and you know
that they can speak English all of them
can speak English like perfect and the
fact that they're sitting there talking
in Romania and then like laughing and
stuff and she's just sitting there going
wow wish somebody would clue me in it to
me that seemed like really rude and it
was like really really frustrating and
then later on in the movie like they do
it at first and it seems kind of
innocuous well not necessarily innocuous
because they're talking about the serial
killer and it's almost kind of like they
don't want her to know about it
um so they're trying to kind of keep it
from her like I said almost trying to
protect her like she's a child and um
but later on like she's at this work
function like a cocktail party and
they're all talking and I'm not gonna
even say what it is because it made me
so mad but like um but her husband
basically me makes a really really
really tasteless joke about the serial
killer and about her fears and stuff
like that to his work colleagues and
they all laugh but and that like it made
me so so angry but but like by that
point she had learned enough Romania
like he didn't know that she was like
learning it so he thought oh we can talk
about all this stuff and she doesn't
know what we're saying which to me like
I said seemed [ __ ] horrible and I was
just kind of like oh my God what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] even though like he
started out like pretty much okay but
like he just got more and more dickish
like as time went on and that to me was
like a super super dick move and I was
just kind of like oh my God I was just
like [ __ ] want to shoot that dude in
the face if he did that that's awful but
like the joke that he made it was like
it was [ __ ] up so I think what upset
me the most about that is the Betrayal
of it I mean she came over here for him
and it's like here's this person he's
supposed to be like supporting you and
have your back and stuff like that and
like I said she kind of gave up I mean
maybe she didn't have anything going on
but she did kind of like move to another
[ __ ] country where she didn't know
anybody and speak the language just for
his job and the fact that he would just
like make fun of her like for like a
cheap laugh
um was just like really shitty but yeah
he just seems like he's trying to
sideline her and her anxieties like all
the time because he just doesn't want to
deal with it and yeah I think that that
really kind of like I that made the
movie like a lot more like uh scary to
me I guess like that kind of stuff is
very scary to me so in short uh too late
probably but if you have shutter this
might be on other streaming services as
well but I watched it on shutter uh it's
been on there for a couple a month or
two I think right now
um and if you're just in the mood for a
very Classic No Frills Hitchcock style
Thriller Watcher is pretty depend
offendably entertaining it's very uh
controlled it's very restrained and as I
said it doesn't really have a lot of
violence or shocks until the end but um
it's actually like a really really great
buildup of dread like throughout the
whole movie and it's not super long like
it's like I said it slowly Pace but I
think it's a good uh build up it's only
about 90 minutes
and I think like Micah Monroe really
sells this kind of like heightening
unease of the narrative like as it's
going on and she's I like her
performance because it's very very
low-key like because you can tell and
maybe this is again my interpretation
but you can tell that she's really
trying not to get hysterical or
emotional or anything like that because
she wants to be believed so she's trying
to make herself seem as stoic and
rational as possible but you can tell
that she's just like simmering
underneath because she's like freaking
out
um but she so she keeps everything very
very low-key and I think that was like a
really good choice I really really like
her in this I think she's like fantastic
and honestly I mean this is really her
movie you know what I mean she's in
pretty much every scene like yeah there
are other characters but she's kind of
the main focus of the whole thing and I
think she did like a really great job so
um honestly I think this is one of the
better Thrillers I've seen in a long
while and uh I have to say too that I'm
looking forward to Chloe acuno's next
project which I think was initially
going to be on Netflix and I don't think
Netflix is going to do it but I think
somebody else has bought it now I think
it's gonna be
um based on the true case of that uh
serial killer Rodney Alcala The Dating
Game Killer I think she's making a movie
uh based on that or at least based on
the woman that chose him on The Dating
Game so I was just kind of like oh I'm
there for that that sounds awesome but
yeah if you've seen it let me know what
you thought about it in the comments and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear I will see you guys again on the
next one bye